يجب أن أقول إنها تجربة غير عادية
أن تكون على متن طائرة حيث تعلم أن كل
مسافر
قد خضع لاختبار
مطمع في المطار لاختبار جواز السفر الجديد
للسفر ،
عليك أن تفكر في هذا ليس حول
ما يحدث
الآن مع رحلة واحدة إلى لندن
ولكن تخيل ذلك  هذه هي الطريقة التي
ستكون عليها لرحلات متعددة
عبر المحيط حيث يصبح الاختبار أكثر
قبولًا من
قبل الحكومات المختلفة ، ثم
سيكون لديك خمسة عشرة أشخاص يعرفون عدد
الرحلات
مع الركاب الذين يقومون باختبار كوفيتش
الآن الذي كان بمثابة قطعة من
الكعكة  ماذا لو كان سيحدث شخص ما
يختبر بشكل إيجابي للغاية إذا كان هناك شخص
ما إيجابيًا ، فسيتم إزالته من هذه
المنطقة ونقله إلى مكان خاص
حيث سيتم الاتصال بمركز السيطرة على الأمراض
وإخطار المنظمات الصحية
المناسبة للمساعدة في دعم هذا العميل الذي سنأخذه
خطوات حتى لا
يكونوا كذلك لن يطيروا في ذلك اليوم من أجل
سلامتهم وسلامة
أي شخص آخر على متن الرحلة من
الركاب المتبقين في روتين لندن الأثير
الأسود
وهكذا بالنسبة إلى الرحلة التي تضمن أن
الجميع سلبي ، مرحبًا
قبل الإقلاع ، تم إخبارنا أن الطائرة قد
تم تعقيمها
، وتم تنظيف كل شيء وهناك
مناديل مبللة على كل مقعد
، قيل لنا أن هناك
أقنعة إضافية متاحة إذا كنت  نحتاج إليهم ،
لذلك نحن في طريقنا إلى لندن ، وقد
علمت منذ
ذلك الحين أن أحد الركاب الذي كان من المفترض
أن يكون على متن الطائرة كان
اختبارًا عميقًا إيجابيًا لفيروس كورونا
المتحدة ، وكان لديه بالفعل خطة في مكان
تم عزل
الشخص والعناية به.  يمكن
لبقية الرحلة
المضي قدمًا بثقة وأمان أكبر ،
وتعتقد بقية الصناعة
أن هذا هو الطريق
إلى الأمام